Welcome back everyone this would be my full marvel
eternals post-credits scene mid-credit scene
breakdown they set up a whole bunch of big things
for marvel phase 4 so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i'll be posting my full breakdown and easter eggs
video for the entire movie next so careful for
spoilers if you have not seen eternals yet we'll
be talking about everything including the blink
and you'll miss it first appearance of marvel's
new blade mahershala ali that's right blade was
in the eternals movie some of you may have spotted
where he showed up during the post-credits
scene but in the first post-credits scene or
the mid-credits scene however you want to call it
makkari druid and thena have taken the domo their
spaceship in search of other eternals on other
planets in the universe with the idea that they're
going to try and awaken them matrix style and
help them break away from the celestial host and
arishem the judge like give them all a bunch of
red pills all with the idea that they're trying to
free everyone from this endless cycle of helping
birth new celestials at the cost of planets it's
implied that when the scene picks up there's been
a small time jump and they still haven't found any
of the other eternals yet around the universe
they complain that they also haven't gotten any
replies back from the other eternals who stayed
on earth that sersi kingo phastos and sprite now
this is coming after the end of the movie we all
saw arishem the judge show up to earth and then
teleport them back to the world forge so we know
what happened to them but these characters don't
then in teleports pit the troll from the comics
swelling a giant mug of booze like you see him in
the comics who jokes about not teleporting
drunk anymore and then introduces star fox
eros from the comics thanos younger brother
played by harry styles he introduces himself
as another eternal just like them his armor is a
version of his red and white comic book costume
but the design the materials are all the same type
of armor suits that the other eternals are wearing
and he reveals that the reason why they haven't
heard from sersi and the others is because arishem
the judge has taken them in eros he knows
how to find them revealing that he is another
prime eternal just like ajak was like sersi became
after ajak passed her special celestial orb to her
he whips his orb out and then they go out on
foreigners feels like the first time and that's
a bit of a clever wink to star fox eros powers in
the comics how he basically has the power to make
people horny but it's also meant to be a reference
to it feeling like the eternal's first mission
again because they have this big cycle of reboots
where they basically wipe their memories and
start over on a new planet so there's a whole
lot going on here in this mid-credit scene to
process but the reason why the orb is a big deal
is because they explained earlier in the movie
it creates a direct connection between the prime
eternal who wields it and arishem the judge
so they need one to track ayrshim down most
of you have probably already guessed where
arishem took the others to the celestial's
world forge that we saw earlier in the movie
the world forge is the place where the eternals
in the deviants were originally created where he
created thousands upon thousands of eternals and
sent them to all different planets of the universe
this is something that they're going to pay off in
eternals 2 the sequel movie some of the eternal's
characters will cross over into other people's
movies before that because it'll take a couple
years to get the sequel out but a lot of this
stuff in the post-credits scene in the mid credits
scene is stuff that they'll directly address
during the next sequel my early prediction right
now is that the world forge is going to wind up
being inside the mcu version of the black galaxy
which is like this really dangerous bermuda
triangle like galaxy inside the marvel universe
it's where ego the living planet came from it's
where thor fought silver surfer for one of the
first times aeroshem had told the others on earth
that he would allow the earth to continue existing
temporarily while he studied their memories
using the eternal's memories from the past seven
thousand years to determine whether or not humans
were worthy to continue existing after which he
would return to earth and the celestial host would
judge the planet and if they judge them to be not
worthy make all the thor jokes you want they would
destroy the planet even though that sounds like
an avengers 5 kind of story i feel like they're
going to save that for the eternal sequel movie
like it'll be eternals versus the celestials and
they'll be trying to convince them not to destroy
the planet while also trying to get the help of
eternals from other planets so star fox or eros
whatever you want to call him is taking them to
the world forge he's thanos's younger brother and
thanos was about a thousand years old according
to the russos during avengers infinity war so
star fox would just be a few years shy of that so
they're not quite as old as thor and not nearly as
old as the other eternal main characters most of
them are millions of years old it's a little more
complicated when you explain eeros's backstory
because he was born to eternal's parents just like
thanos was a lars was basically like the prime
eternal of titan like the version of ajak on titan
the person who led all their people that's one of
the reasons why pith the troll introduces him as
the prince of titan pip the troll was a really
weird side character who was featured heavily
during the thanos infinity gauntlet saga in the
comics he was mostly like a court jester kind of
character who just got drunk all the time spilling
from that giant tankard eventually he did get the
space stone and teleported all over the universe
one of his other abilities was being able to
find anyone anywhere in the universe kind of the
same way that heimdall can find anyone anywhere
so his scene here at the end of the movie just
kind of winks that with the way he teleports in
also a bit of another thor easter egg here too
the way they teleport onto their ship is using
bifrost technology that's why it looks like the
rainbow effect the same way when they're using
the bifrost in the thor movies when pip says the
eros is from mystery planet and he's the defeater
of black roger black roger was a character the
eros fought on mystery planet to try and save this
girl during an avengers spotlight comic book in
a story called the comedy of eros he defeated him
using some creative teleporting technology so the
fact that they mention mystery planet in black
roger is just a bit of a wink at what's happening
here with him teleporting onto the domo i'll do
a longer video all about star fox's character
his future in the mcu later this weekend after
people have a chance to see the movie a little
bit more but in the final post-credits scene kit
harington's dane whitman is at his uncle's castle
or manor house in england very large estate he
opens a case containing the actual ebony blade in
the ebony blades wrapped in this special shroud
that looks kind of like it still has blood on it
there's a carving in latin inside the case that
reads death is my reward mors mihi lucrum, the
blade whispers to him with many different voices
all on top of each other it collects souls of the
beings that it kills which is what the voices are
the souls of the people who have been killed by
the blade over hundreds and hundreds of years
he starts to psych himself up saying that he has
to try like he's unsure and he slowly reaches out
to touch the blade the surface of the blade
starts moving around like inky black water
kind of the same way that the necro sword in the
comics has fluidic properties making it seem like
his armor his black knight armor will form around
him coming out of the blade sort of like a magical
version of the way that iron man's nanite armor or
black panther's vibranium armor forms around them
and just before his fingers touch the blade
off screen this is our mahershala ali blade
cameo scene first appearance of mcu blade anywhere
canonically inside the mcu you don't actually see
him on screen off screen he says are you sure
you're ready for that dane whitman and then it
just cuts to black to the credits so why did they
have a cameo scene for mahershala ali's blade
inside the eternals post credit scene with the
black knight is he going to be doing something
with the black knight will the black knight show
up in the new blade movie i think that's what
they're trying to tell us is that's the next place
we're going to see kit harington's black knight
character like he'll be using the ebony blade to
fight vampires with blade in europe somewhere it's
also kind of funny if you think about it because
eternals live forever essentially eternally who
else lives for a long time vampires you could
also make a joke about blade appearing in a scene
about a blade i'll talk more about black knight
and blade crossover when i do that separate kit
harington black knight video later this weekend
but it's implied that his uncle is dead when he's
opening that case if you've never read any of
the comic book stories with the black knight the
whole idea is that his uncle was the previous
black knight before him to wield the blade and
it was the evil version of the character in the
comics so in the comics generation to generation
the black knight is either a villain or a hero
when dane whitman takes up the ebony blade and
becomes the black knight he tries to rehabilitate
the name of his family so that people don't think
of them as villains anymore that was what he was
talking about when he was talking to sersi about
his family history being quote unquote complicated
so it's very clear that dane whitman knows
all about the ebony blade and the curse that it
carries in the curse of his family in the history
of the black knight like this isn't the first time
that he's seen the blade the curse that the ebony
blade carries is that it thirsts for blood the
more blood the blade spills the more the wielder
becomes filled with the bloodlust berserker rage
the way kid harington described it in interviews
recently he talked about it like an addiction
like you become addicted to the blade you just
want to spill more and more blood sersi implied
earlier in the movie that he had had some strife
with his uncle like they hadn't been speaking
to each other and that probably had something
to do with his uncle succumbing to the curse of
the blade and turning into a full-blown villain
if you've read the berserk manga it's a lot
like the berserker armor so it carries a
very terrible price but it makes you incredibly
powerful the ebony blade protects him against
magical attacks it can cut pretty much anything
including adamantium he can summon it to himself
the same way that thor summons stormbreaker in
his hammer he can also teleport himself to the
blade's location from anywhere he doesn't need to
be touching it in order to do that so it has a lot
of storm breaker like properties my assumption
is is the way they're setting this up in the mcu
it'll be kind of like a relic level item the
way they talk about it in the doctor strange
movie the way baron mordo talked about the staff
of the living tribunal magic that was so powerful
that in order to contain it they bound it to an
item there were a couple other big references to
the black knight throughout the film as well so
at the beginning of the film sersi gives him his
family's ring that's hundreds of years old has his
family's crest on it the crest of the black knight
as i said she also is the one that told him
you always meant to make up with your uncle
now is the time to do it then when the eternals go
back to their ship on the domo for the first time
in present day thena picks up a sword and starts
swinging it around and sprite asks her if it's the
ebony blade she says no it's excalibur like the
actual excalibur from the king arthur chronicles
and they joke about what king arthur was like in
real life meaning that camelot within the mcu was
a real place in history the king arthur mythology
was all real mcu history so this also gets into
the whole origin story behind the black knight
in the comics and kit harington's family line
the original black knight was named sir percy he
came from camelot in the time of king arthur's
court the ebony blade itself was forged by merlin
meaning that it's possible that merlin could have
been the sorcerer supreme during that era or if
the ancient one was still alive at that point
he studied under the ancient one so the whole
idea is that if the eternals were around for
the events of camelot like they stayed at camelot
and knew king arthur and his court all the other
people that lived then that means that sersi also
knew dane whitman's ancestor the sir percy black
knight and she knows all about who he really is
and probably picked up his family's ring back then
next time i see you you'll be all in black so
it's implied at the beginning of the film when she
gives him the ring she didn't find it on ebay she
just lied about that she had it in her possession
this whole time for hundreds and hundreds of years
but just like i'm planning on doing another longer
star fox video i'll do a longer video for kit
harington's black knight character and what he's
going to be doing next and how they're going to
pay that character off but obviously he will be
in the eternal sequel movies as well if you have
any other questions about what was going on during
the mid credit scene or the post credit scene just
write them in the comments below my full easter
eggs and breakdown video for the entire movie will
post tomorrow make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss anything you can
click here to watch that full easter egg video for
the entire movie i'll update the link as soon as
i post that tomorrow and click here for my other
eternals video about how thanos actually saved
the avengers in the earth from the celestials
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!